almost a month since its spectacular
blast off from french guiana the james
webb space telescope has traveled one
and a half million kilometers to its
celestial observation post we're now at
our orbital destination and soon enough
be able to make amazing discoveries
from its vantage point webb will train
its huge light collecting mirrors to the
farthest distances in the universe it
makes its observations not in the
visible range of light but in the
infrared part of the spectrum
that will enable it to essentially see
through the vast clouds of dust and gas
that obscure the view webb will look
back at over 13 and a half billion years
of cosmic history to the origins of the
very first galaxies formed after the big
bang that prospect of finding things
that completely surprise us that sort of
changed the way we understand the
universe that is what i'm most excited
about with this telescope the 10 billion
telescope unfolded its complex array of
mirrors infrared cameras spectrographs
and sun shields without a hitch because
infrared instruments are extremely
sensitive to heat webb will now spend
several months cooling down to minus 233
degrees celsius we expect the first
science images from jwst to come back in
about five months so be getting excited
getting ready for those to come back
later on this summer and we can expect
really spectacularly beautiful images to
come back from this awesome new
telescope webb's mission of discovery
may last as long as 20 years a
pathfinder seeking answers to cosmic
questions alone among the silent stars
rob reynolds al jazeera